madame la Présidente
madame la Première ministre
madame la ministre messieurs les
ministres mesdames les ministres pardon
messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues
le premier qui se réveille
réveille les autres
disent les enfants
les premiers à être réveillés ont été
les Ukrainiens
ils savaient depuis longtemps en tout
cas depuis 2014 ce que nous voulions
ignorer depuis plus longtemps encore
à savoir que les puissances occidentales
n'avaient pas vraiment gagné la guerre
froide même si l’union soviétique
l'avait clairement perdu nos amis nos
frères du Crêts ont éprouvé dans leur
cœur et dans leur chair ce que nous
avons longtemps
obstinément
inconsidémie inconsidérément refusé de
voir nos trions apparents des années 90
n'avait assuré durablement et
universellement ni la souveraineté des
peuples ni la démocratisation des états
ni la liberté des consciences des
opinions et des mouvements l'invasion
arbitraire injustifiée et terriblement
meurtrière de la libre crène par une
puissance impérialiste
la tragiquement montrée aujourd'hui les
souffrances et les victoires de
l'Ukraine nous confirment dans une
conviction que les Français ont été trop
longtemps les seuls à professer dans
l'Union européenne cette conviction
c'est celle qui veut que l'Europe ces
valeurs ses intérêts sa culture et ses
lois ne pourront survivre dans le monde
qui nous attend si les européens
continuent de faire de leur union une
entité simultanément marchande et
éthérés naïve a dit le président de la
République étrangère en toute état cause
à toute logique de puissance nous autres
Français avons de longues dates pensées
que l'universalisme de nos valeurs ne
pouvaient nous dispenser de l'obligation
d'inscrire notre projet dans un
territoire particulier fragile et
menacée ce petit cap de aussi décrit par
Paul Valéry et que personne ne défendra
durablement s'il ne se défend pas
lui-même nous avons passionnément voulu
donner une dimension géopolitique au
projet européen ajoutez la force au
droit la réciprocité à l'exemplarité les
intérêts aux valeurs l'ambition à la
poste là la défense et la division d'une
culture à la défense de l'humanisme les
Ukrainiens nous ont réveillé ils nous
ont dit par l'invasion qu'ils ont subi
par la résistance qui lui ont opposé par
les souffrances assumées par les deuils
accumulées où est notre devoir ce qu'est
notre mission quelles sont nos
responsabilités en défendant sa
souveraineté ses libertés sa démocratie
l'Ukraine défauts notre souveraineté nos
libertés nos démocraties on est dans
l'Ukraine à se défendre les Ukrainiens
défendent l'Europe
nous avons pu mesurer aux côtés de la
présidente de notre assemblée la
détermination du président Zelenski et
derrière lui celle de tout un peuple un
peuple inventif mobilisé actifs et
entreprenant un peuple impavide devant
les provocations les référendums bidons
les mascarades cérémoniales qui visent
au sublime et une rencontre que le
grotesque nous devons mes chers
collègues être à la hauteur des
responsabilités que nous impose la
situation nous sommes à la veille de
grandes épreuves elles imposent et
sacrifices aux Ukrainiens les Russes ont
pas besoin de recourir à l'arbre
nucléaire pour nous atteindre dans notre
confort et dans notre relatif quiétude à
nous non plus on ne sort pas vainqueur
d'une telle épreuve sans force d'âme
sans énergie sans rejet des divisions
bien sûr nous avons aussi un devoir de
sagesse le souci d'éviter la
généralisation de la guerre le dérapage
vers les armes de destruction la
préservation des chances de la paix le
monde peut compter sur nous pour
travailler dès que ce sera possible et
avec qui ce sera possible au
rétablissement de la paix mais l'issue
du conflit passera par le respect
scrupuleux de la souveraineté de
l'Ukraine l'établissement de garantie de
sécurité sérieuse et crédible et la
reconstruction d'un pays martyre
aujourd'hui l'heure est à la solidarité
inconditionnelle avec le peuple
ukrainien et que serait notre solidarité
sinon une abject hypocrisie si nous
n'apportun pas aux Ukrainiens les moyens
de se défendre et de vivre il n'y a pas
d'amour sans preuve d'amour il n'y a pas
de solidarité sans preuve de solidarité
l'Europe et pour la première fois depuis
la fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
confrontée à une responsabilité
historique majeure ensemble relevons ce
grand défi il en va de notre avenir à
tous que vivent l'Ukraine que vive la
France que vive l'Europe
[Applaudissements]